I actually look at Trump and you notice
that Trump doesn't do a lot of this
stuff as a businessman he's shaking
hands with everybody he's loving on
everybody once you're a Multi multi
Multi multi billionaire then you're like
okay I'm gonna say it and I'm gonna say
it loud and screw you if you don't like
and dude I personally I think it's the
reason he won because if you look at
everyone else look at every other
politician that was up there on the
stage everybody is measured in
everything that they say and then look
when they when they came after him this
this I think was the moment for a whole
lot of people and if you go back and you
watch this moment like you see the
reaction from the crowd is they try to
corner him with the question and they
say to him you said this about women you
said that they were fat ugly pigs or
megyn kelly yeah she first question she
asked him the question most other
politician is so measured that they're
gonna say well you gotta understand like
we were in a bar and Trump says what
only Rosie O'Donnell okay because that's
what she is she's a fat pig okay
horrible horrible woman and because he
was willing to do that people said maybe
I don't agree with everything he says
but it's a breath of fresh air to
finally have someone that you just feel
like is telling you the truth even if
you don't agree with it you at least
feel like they're being authentic how
does Trump you know in our PC culture
these days where people are getting
fired for doing the littlest thing Trump
will say anything that's on his mind
holds no bar but he doesn't you know how
does that resonate
that's not me picking on Trump that's
now I'm just kind of throw think only if
they only have power over you and
control over you if you care so if you a
need to keep your job if you B want to
keep your friends if you see like like
need this opportunity like Trump wants
to keep his job doesn't no he doesn't he
doesn't want to keep his job he doesn't
play like he wants to keep his job you
only played the only part that he's
playing right now where he doesn't keep
his job at a what part it is let me tell
what it is yeah it's interest rates its
interest rates
let me tell what I mean by interest
rates he had panel Kate Powell keep
saying what
low rates low rates low rates low rates
what is low rates do what is lowering
rates do lets you borrow more money as
much as you what is it due to Dow Jones
keep it above 27,000 peanuts okay it's
gonna get it between 27 or 32 and that's
what Trump wants right the moment he
gets reelected one of the first things
he needs to do I don't know whether he's
gonna bring rates raising they have to
raise okay
so meaning if you're about to refinance
your home doing in the next five months
you you're now gonna be refinancing a
twenty twenty-one if you're wanting to
sell your house sell it now your
property value is gonna go down in 2021
and it's gonna go down a good percentage
bar though because what happens with
rates rates go up price goes down rates
go down price goes it's just basic
arbitrage math we're doing right okay so
that part I think he plays with that
stuff I think he knows how to place
cards right on you know what things to
do to you know help him stay reelected
right but does he come from a place
where he needs to campaign money from
the bar right now he doesn't come from
that standpoint Trump gets reelected
does he just I mean he's crazy right now
I mean the stuff he does is he doesn't
get what kind of levels I mean he's not
gonna give two shits right I mean if
he's ever wanted to go after Hillary or
Obama or any these guys he's gonna do it
on a second term he won't do don't first
didn't go after them put exactly exactly
what was said he would do to Hillary put
her in jail what they did to him if he's
ever gonna do it he won't do it or if
he's gonna do it I'm not saying he's
gonna do it okay aside from that I'm
talking just the things he says the
things he does he's got nothing to lose
it that what are you gonna go what is he
gonna win is he gonna get the house and
the Senate you think is gonna get both
of them no no no okay so what do you
think okay let's say he gets reelected
what do you think is gonna happen say he
gets reelected what are the chances he
gets reelected you're 85% you're going
to 85 you're going I'm going
80 plus the only logo in 50 look the
only the only way to do it's 50/50 you
look the only way that they beat him
honestly and I don't even know if that
would work but I it's the thing I'm most
scared of is if they have a brokered
convention and they put Michelle Obama
in
that to me is the only way she's the
x-factor for you she is probably the
only one that I think actually has a
shot against Trump and I'm gonna tell
you why she's not brother people are fed
up like I don't think that people
realize okay they are getting played
right now in fact Trump is playing every
one of these governors so you see all of
this hogwash and all the stuff that's
happening and you've watched it ever
since coronavirus started you've what
you've seen all this government
overreach you see these governors that
are mandating this shutting stuff down
shutting down businesses hurting
people's paychecks and then all of a
sudden you see the looting and the
rioting and such Trump is allowing this
stuff right now to happen and he's
sitting back because you're seeing so
many people get pissed off at their
state and local governments and all of
the overreach from the democratic
governors and mayors and and such there
there's people that are getting so
pissed off and people will do more Pat
tell me if I'm wrong here people are
more motivated by hatred than they are
by love okay and when you hate something
you go out and you vote against it and
trust me right now Trump is sitting back
and he's playing the left like a fiddle
and they don't even realize that they're
playing into his checkmate what is he
doing that he's playing them exactly
he's he's he's giving them enough rope
to hang themselves the governor yes so
Pat knows because he watches my debate
tactics one of my debate tactics is is
this let the other guy talk and talk and
talk and talk and when you let him talk
eventually he's gonna say the wrong
thing and at that moment you swoop in
for your kill this is what Trump is
doing right now he's saying sure you
know what do like let flippin and Tifa
and all these groups take over downtown
Seattle and set up Chas okay I don't
know what that's doing that's pissing
off a lot of people that are normally
liberals and they're sitting there like
what the heck is going on I can't go to
work I can't do this they're seeing all
of these protests and they're being told
they're being told oh you can't go to
work because we're afraid that you're
gonna come within six feet of people but
then the same Democratic governors and
stuff we're saying everybody should go
protest we're not going to do any
and when people see the double standard
it pisses them off and I cannot tell you
how many people right now and I'll prove
it to you that I'll shut up okay you had
in California which is a blue blue blue
blue state
you had a seat that in this last special
election just a few months ago they had
a special election for Katie Katie hill
or something
for her seat it was like plus seven blue
it flipped plus five red in a in
California because people just fed up
they're sick and tired of it well the
good thing about that is we're gonna see
in about 150 days right we're about
three months out what do we rely on
September October November
how many months in a year now we got
July oh you got exactly five months well
I was gonna get you know less the two
days less than five months we're gonna
find out what's gonna happen
[Music]